hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
right here in front of me are
three m1 ipad pros the 11 inch right
here with eight gigs of memory
and two 12.9 inches one with eight
and one with 16 gigs but we're not going
to focus on that in this video
we're going to put those off to the side
and look at the mini led displays
later in this video we're focusing on
the m1 ipad pro
versus the 2020 a12z
ipad pro we're going to look at all the
differences we're gonna compare the
facetime cameras because it is different
on the new one we're gonna look at the
microphones the speakers to see if they
changed and of course
the performance between the a12z and the
m1
to see how big of a jump there really is
between these two so i'm really excited
for this video
so let's get right into it now before we
get started i do want to mention that
the magic keyboard case fits both of
them perfectly
there you go there's the old 11 inch
and here is the new 11 inch perfectly
fine
no issues with the magic keyboard case
so
that's definitely nice if you already
have the old magic keyboard case and you
want to upgrade to the new ipad pro
but for now let's set this aside all
right now starting on the back you can
see that they're
basically identical obviously this one's
space gray
this one is silver we have that dual
camera setup right there with the lidar
scanners
the flash and the microphone everything
on the back is basically identical but
if you look at those speaker grills you
can see that there are less of them
on the new ipad pro and they are closer
to the center
that's going to be nice when you're
playing some games and holding it like
this
you have less of a chance of blocking
those speaker grilles
so that's definitely a plus that apple
chose to do that
now on the bottom both of these have a
usbc port but
on the new m1 ipad pro you actually get
thunderbolt support
which means that you can plug in
accessories
like this ssd the sabrint extreme
rocket ssd with very fast speeds and we
actually tested it
and it works on this m1 ipad pro in the
other video against
the m1 macbook pro we showed that off so
definitely check out the video if you
haven't already the first thing i really
want to test
is that new front-facing camera so let's
go ahead and
go into the camera set it to the reverse
and basically everything looks the same
i'm surprised because the quality
between these two even if you just look
like this
the quality is matching on the new ipad
pro even though this has an
ultra wide camera check this out boom
you can see my face
let me do that meme look at that
that's actually so cool that you have
that
really wide sensor i also want to show
you guys the quality difference between
the webcam
and the microphones as well and as you
can tell this is the
2020 ipad pro and this is a very very
tight shot and now here we are on the
ipad pro obviously you're not going to
use this mode you're going to use the
center stage mode which will
automatically kind of
crop in and follow your face wherever
you are but man the quality on this
ultra wide lens
is really really good and you guys let
me know how the microphone quality is as
well
now with that said i want to test out
the speakers to see if there's any
difference in quality
or volume with the new ipad pro compared
to the old one so let's get right into
[Music]
it
[Music]
to be completely honest i didn't notice
any difference but maybe you guys did
and if you did go ahead and comment down
below and if you haven't already
subscribe because we got those other
ipad pro videos coming up soon now let's
finally get into the performance
benchmarking and testing and as you can
see we have geekbench five opened up
and right here you can see we have six
gigs of ram on the 2020 ipad pro
and eight on the m1 ipad pro and you can
see the arm
at 3.2 gigahertz that's the m1 and the
a12z
at 2.49 gigs so let's go ahead and run
the cpu benchmark we have our scores and
i've got to say this is just insane
because i don't know how apple managed
to put in this much performance
into the same exact chassis we have 1700
single core compared to around 1100
that's 53 more and for multi-core
7251 compared to 4724
that is also 53 more performance
that is such a huge difference i
honestly was not
expecting that crazy of a difference and
now let's go ahead and go
on to the compute graphics benchmark
now this is what i did not expect
the new ipad pro with the m1 chip is 82
faster in terms of graphics performance
that's crazy
21.5 000 compared to almost 12 000
i did not expect that big of a
difference from generation to generation
now moving on we have a brand new test
geekbench ml which
recently came out so we're going to be
comparing this we have the back end set
to core
ml on both of these alright guys we got
our scores and this
is where the new 16 core neural engine
in the
m1 chip is being put to work 2600 on the
m1
1300 on the 812 z
that's 95 faster performance
for machine learning tasks that's
really really impressive now moving on
to the next test i want to test out
speedometer that's a web
browsing test so basically it's going to
show you how snappy
web browsing and things like that are
going to be on these ipads so
let's go ahead and start look at that
214 compared to 137
that's 56 faster general
web browsing performance so even though
people say you can't
get all of that m1 ship you are
definitely going to notice a snappier
experience
when browsing the web and doing stuff
like that moving on to the next test we
have 3dmark
wildlife so let's turn on the unlimited
mode
on both of these and start it no way
guys
this does not make sense i can't believe
there's such a massive difference we
have 18 300
for the m1 300 for the a12z that doesn't
really make sense unless this is
factoring in and taking advantage of
everything the cpu the graphics
the 16 core neural engine this is just
crazy crazy performance on to the next
one we have gfx bench metal this is kind
of like a realistic
gaming benchmark we're going to load up
1440p asset ruins high tier
off screen that's interesting the ipad
pro
the m1 is loading a lot faster so i
think that has to do with the
storage speed so i guess that means that
the storage is quite a bit faster than
on the old
a12z ipad pro all right it looks like
the m1 ipad pro got 82.2 fps compared to
57 so that's 42
faster graphics performance in gfx bench
metal and now finally let's finish off
with the most
real real world test that we can make
this is adobe rush
and we have the same clips with the same
effects added
and what we're gonna do is basically
just export it and see
how much faster the m1 ipad pro is we
have the same export settings
we got high quality 24fps 4k and let's
go ahead and
export it this is so weird guys we're
approaching the finish
the a12c ipad pro just finished faster
that makes no
sense at all 95 96
on the m1 97 and
done that is so weird
the m1 was 12 seconds slower i have no
idea why
but maybe this shows that it's using the
encoding
chips that are built into these apple
silicon chips i have no idea but
it looks like for video editing there's
really not much difference
all right there you guys go that was the
full comparison between the m1 ipad pro
and the a12z
2020 ipad pro and apart from that weird
video editing test the new one is
definitely much more powerful
much more snappy and one thing is very
clear
if you're gonna be buying this 800 ipad
pro
it's basically as future proof as you're
gonna get because i can't see them
coming out with a much better or much
faster ipad pro within the next couple
of years
so if you buy this now it's definitely
much more future proof and i would
recommend
just going for the brand new 800 model
instead of trying to find the 2020 a12z
model
maybe on sale or used definitely spend
the extra cash get a
brand new m1 because this is future
proof especially with that thunderbolt
port so
hopefully you guys enjoy this video and
if you did definitely click that circle
about to subscribe
to see our 8 gig versus 16 gig 12.9 inch
ipad pro comparison
and if you want to see some more videos
check out one of those two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video